mandy moore is taking us down uh a
member no no i always get this saying
wrong a memory lane trip in a trip down
memory lane even when it's written in
front of me i can't get it right by
re-watching her first major blockbuster
a walk to remember for the first time in
a decade celebrating the films
does this make you feel old 20th
anniversary wow yeah yes she even had a
box of tissues standing by because we
know that she's gonna need it so
i want a box of tissues for how old i
feel right now
enjoy see you tomorrow
so today marks the 20th anniversary of a
walk to remember being in theaters i
haven't seen the movie in over a decade
and i can't think of a better way to
celebrate than to watch the movie with
all of you
a little mood lighting
[Music]
just in case
[Applause]
my house
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Applause]
i don't think getting out was gonna be
your problem
it's more like figuring out what you're
gonna do when you get somewhere i mean
can you understand why i had the biggest
crush ever on shane west come on